so after nearly three years  investigating the french catholic church  a commission says about 330 000 children  were victims of sexual abuse over 70  years the landmark report says about 3  000 child abusers two-thirds of whom  were priests operated within the church  since the 1950s the report details what  it calls a complete indifference on the  part of the church towards the victims  catholic bishops in france called for an  independent inquiry in 2018 to shed  light on past abuses  it seemed indispensable in our  investigation to look at everything that  can feed or justify abuses and sexual  violence and that includes a form of  exaggerating the priest's authority and  an excessive sacrilization as well as  the identification of the priest to  christ in all aspects of his life  the commission has found that an outlook  excessively taboo of sexuality is  susceptible in creating blind spots to  very grave abuses